by the way those Nike dad hats man they  owe you a check for those damn man Nike  pun intended by the way you had those  Nike dad hats popping yeah it was crazy  did you notice like when you were  wearing that hat like everyone started  wearing the Nike like just the Vintage  like Nike almost like the Tiger Woods  hat kind of low-key you know took a  while for me to realize and then I  started noticing yeah yeah everybody  that everybody's wearing their dad at  you definitely yeah you were I would say  you were kind of the originator of dad  hats in hip-hop looking yeah I would say  I definitely am you are 100 yeah yeah  but it's on a round of applause  everybody in here we are wearing dad  hats because of pen Griffey you know  what I'm saying